city of angels famous for its movie
stars stunning coastline and healthy
lifestyle the ideal place to have a
healthy restaurant but in spite of its
location sante la brea is in critical
condition it's chewy it's like meat but
not dean the owner and his two sons
arthur and sammy have been running sante
for nearly 10 years dry red wine so what
does that mean not only drink bro but
business has dwindled to almost nothing
and this father-son team is in desperate
need of gordon ramsay's help
i'm the owner i am the cook i'm a
janitor i also do all the maintenance
there's a water storage with a thin very
thin thread i'm holding this place slime
you want to take his table maybe dad
should hell [ __ ] no you want it to be
good right this place is running like
without a [ __ ] captain i don't think
my dad can really be a manager how about
you just man up man sack up and do this
[ __ ] man i always wanted to be
surrounded with good intelligent strong
people i needed help like genuine help i
hired mark about six months ago there's
a lot of food here i don't know who it's
for my role here is a little bit
undefined it was really no job title
i'll be the hostess i'm the best hostess
we don't know we don't know what he does
i think of mark moore of the interior
decorator i want to make it feel like a
nice welcoming home i do what needs to
be done i treat it as though it's mine
i've worked here since i was 15 years
old i don't remember the last time it
was like busy just hold your breath it's
only seven o'clock the nightmare is the
fact that i'm not making money my father
is in at least two hundred thousand
dollar debt i owe everybody i owe the
landlord taxes vendors short on my
mortgage it's really sad i
i gave it my all i
it's my heart and my soul my time
all right everything is uh in jeopardy i
stand to lose everything
i think we need chefs and ramsey's help
because we don't know what the [ __ ]
we're doing
[Music]
everyone at sante la brea is getting
ready for chef ramsay's arrival i'm
nervous and excited about meeting chef
ramsay it's like being awake in a dream
i really didn't show up [ __ ] aurelio
didn't show up again but owner dean has
just received upsetting news he locked
his phone and his home phone phone is on
us
aurelio hey where are you man i need you
his head chef aurelio is nowhere to be
found come over okay i really need you
today
okay bye it really was a no-show today
so it's like uh
what else is new [ __ ] christ
i'm a little bit nervous to meet chef
ramsay i heard that guy's like [ __ ]
two and [ __ ] like he's a [ __ ] monster
[Music]
la brea avenue one of the busiest
streets in l.a and home to hundreds of
successful restaurants one thing's for
sure the location is not an issue i'm
about to find out what is
my god
how are you chef ramsay thank you so
much
yes it is good to see you good to see
you too so
this is different
yes it's welcome to my place it is
different give me a little tour a little
tour okay this has been remodeled lately
not too long ago
and i just put that in together it's
supposed to be wheat grass
growing yeah
you grew that yes we do
oh
jesus christ almighty
actually is that there
[Music]
excellent
okay
i'm not gonna give it to you
oh [ __ ]
me huh it's something about chef ramsay
it just freezes a part of your
your brain so
the food tell me about the food is it
all
vegan vegetarian no we're we have
chicken and fish chicken and fish yes
vegan
everything in the kitchen is made made
in two versions either vegan versions or
non vegan versions how many shits you
got in the brigade
what a head [ __ ] i have actually i have
none today
my chef didn't show up is he sick is he
i don't know he's just
vanished everyone takes advantage of me
i'm not really making money i actually
was spending money for last year what's
the problems with the restaurant
straight off what is it really money
money is the issue here mark spent five
thousand dollars on these things they
bought five thousand dollars worth of
products products so mark's your partner
mark is not my partner he's just lend me
ten thousand dollars mark is just a big
talker he just talks too much he makes
makes many ideas he doesn't follow up
with nice to meet you good to see you
nice to meet you really so much about
you explain to me what you do
um right now i've been trying to make
the place just a little more hip a
little more fresh a little more modern
right okay tell me about the design what
are you what's the vision here there
want to be like no other place you've
ever seen
you're definitely definitely
not wrong there that's for sure thank
you thank you
i'm dying to get something to eat get up
to speed i've tasted some grass
do you want to pick a little bit hot i'm
gonna sit outside the terrace and i'll
bring you a menu get some fresh air
nice to meet you mark nice to meet you
too
thank you sweaty hands
your hands are sweaty mine yeah i'm very
hot i'm very hot and i only wear this
for you and it's hot so i can change it
now
he is h.o.t
[Laughter]
[Music]
good afternoon ramsey
okay and then i'm fascinated uh which
i've never come across before murgadufu
what is that it's like a it's like
it's like a stir-fry mixed vegetable
stir-fry with them with black bean sauce
it's a little bit spicy
okay and then i'll finish off the
blackened salmon thank you brilliant all
right get it
wow
mono tofu
butter tofu hold on away i grab the
order man come on hey what's the dog's
name please
tubs
tricky patty mills turkey patty
mountains
[Music]
what is he eating right now that he's
looking like he's picking through it
like it's dog [ __ ]
turkey melts my gosh
[Music]
if this restaurant prides itself on
being healthy that does not look healthy
that is dry
and they are disgusting
come here
look smell tubs there you go
a little bit more tubs there you go
buddy
he's feeding the turkey patios of the
dog dude
i saw him feeding the burger to the dog
first i'm so glad the dog ate i was so
glad because i thought if the dog
doesn't eat this burger we're [ __ ] uh
this here is a mobu dofu
oh come on this is a joke he doesn't
like it i didn't do means [ __ ] in
chinese that's for sure
he's looking laughing
rice cooked to hell
and
[Music]
i'm stuck here
i'm a center labrea
oh come on that
is shocking my god
that's where he was that's what he was
ripping apart
oh that's horrible though
maybe he can get through
to dean about the food
you can smell it you can taste it it's
[ __ ] and this is the salmon here
blackened salmon black and salmon
absolutely okay very black
[Music]
it's dry and it tastes
[Music]
way too fishy for salmon like it's been
in a
refrigeration unit that's not even
properly
cool disgusting
god the food is bad
[Music]
how was it just in terms of the
presentation it looked like a dog's
dinner
then you get to taste it
it's hideous healthy food yeah does not
have to look like [ __ ] and taste crap
i agree with you so
oh god
jesus
oh not that bad show me where the salmon
is it was smelling fishy i'm [ __ ]
believable
fresh salmon oh dear that's wild salmon
when did he come in yesterday yesterday
my salmon was very fishy you got all
that in there yesterday yes yeah and so
you got the some of the turkey
in the same container melting so the
chicken comes in fresh yes it does
i guess this is extra you know whenever
we have it
[Music]
why are you lying no i'm not lying to
you this is not exactly what i expected
to find in a healthy restaurant what
else is in here
one of chef ramsay found all the stuff
that's been there for a long time it's
rotten it was
very disturbing to me your food is about
as healthy as these vegetables i didn't
realize that nobody looks in the
refrigerator we're gonna serve this
tonight no all of a sudden dean there's
a lot of food in there that you're not
serving when i smell [ __ ] i i go
straight for the [ __ ] juggler
i felt destroyed it was unbelievable i
feel like breaking down completely i
let the chef take care of the
the refrigerator i don't look into it
this is your business yes it is
it's true
there's nothing for me to say the
biggest problem this restaurant
is you
congratulations
it's a [ __ ] disgrace
[Music]
after gordon discovered the deplorable
conditions of the food storage it's
rotten
owner dean is devastated
[Music]
they got very emotional i felt like the
hopelessness kind of feeling from him
you know in a way and it was really
[ __ ] sad what happened today man will
not happen again because we got mr
borden on the other side yeah you get
your goddamn rhino will never it again
and all these things supposed to be
dumped by god damn rio yesterday okay
there is
where have you been all right take bring
that somewhere
two hours late chef aurelio finally
shows up for work you better [ __ ]
deal with this like a man that's all i
gotta say
what happened with all this stuff inside
the refrigerator is all bad and moldy
and [ __ ] and stuff like that we should
have dumped it before do you remember
eggplant's supposed to be dumped you
know
it's okay who cares man we had a [ __ ]
up situation today man can we even trust
this guy can we trust you anymore or
what i mean i don't know
no man we trust him
take him back with open arms yeah
seriously it's the
my dad's got no balls man he got no
balls in terms of this he can't get rid
of him
can you get inside and look and see
what's going on please take care of
everything
i'm distressed you know i can't serve
any food without i'm stuck here i have
no choice i gotta keep him because i
would have no one otherwise
i'd see the tears for me dad i really
want to cry
[Music]
sorry man
[Applause]
all these chaos all these confusions
this the worst thing can happen to a
restaurant owner actually it's kind of
cringing to me it makes me feel bad
[Music]
for for dinner
come on with me please
judy's burgers it is and for yourself
sir uh the saffron
now that chef aurelio is here for dinner
gordon has an opportunity to see if the
restaurant food is any better when the
chef is around
did you see the fridge
yeah yeah anything to say or no i don't
know
nothing to say it's my fault he knows
it's my fault i guess it is it is my
responsibility after all i'm just cooked
i'm not interested i can do whatever i
want here so you know that's why i never
go somewhere else
i need pants
pants i need pants do you have some more
pants ready no
the chef had to put the stuff back in
the fridge they didn't
why are you scared of the chefs
uh because if they leave nobody gonna be
served aurelio is one of those entities
in my life that i can live with and i
can live without i'm tired dude
we have uh
mediterranean platters like hummus
tabbouleh that's great i've gone for
pita that's not good it's too heavy
it's not the worst
it's not the best though
it's an hour into service and dinner
conversation at this restaurant is
primarily about the poor food we might
afford
whatever you know will you
excited about eating healthily this
evening no we're not very happy with
this no right
having heard the general sentiment of
the customers gordon heads back to the
kitchen to get to the root of the
problem
jesus christ
oh my god
oh my god
and what is that
what's going on all together
and duck it's duck but it's
fake fake duck
fake duck
so you call it what we call untuck
under under right now i feel like i'm
getting completely [ __ ] is that
popular yeah it is actually a lot of
people ask for that too
[Music]
[ __ ] duck [ __ ]
ass fake fish
fight fish
and it looks like fish and tastes like
fish and it's got seaweed on on the
outside we have everything that's on
this is incredible so far i've had under
unfished and unfucking believable what a
mess not my favorite no
hey
god bless los angeles
after a disappointing dinner service
thank you so much i hope you guys see
you guys again thanks again have a great
week
gordon confronts the staff with the
harsh reality of the situation
i'm somewhat confused um
nobody seems to
take and accept responsibility
everybody's a free-for-all no rules no
one's fear for the job just a lack of
care i think a manager needs to make
sure that things happen all these things
that are unattended to i i have to take
blame for it's all me for some reason
people are not listening to me my
management style is not functional it's
not working let me tell you yeah what
the problem is here at sonte lack of
management yeah that's clear that's
happening but let me tell you the
biggest problem here
the biggest problem here is the food not
just the food
it's the [ __ ] everything's a gimmick
on chicken and duck your philosophy is
not healthy style the [ __ ] i uncovered
in the freezer the discovery in the
fridge you've got grass hanging from the
ceiling it's like [ __ ] lord of the
flies up there have you seen this [ __ ]
hovering around
there i am not going any further until
this place
is [ __ ] clean and i mean spotless
if a health inspector had witnessed one
eyewitness just in one of the fridges
bang game over clean this [ __ ] pigsty
this place
does not deserve an a
and the only thing you're getting from
me tonight is that
an f
there they're staying on
and guys i'll take it down tomorrow
personally yeah when it's up to the
standard of an a now move your [ __ ]
asses
there they're staying on after giving
sante la brea an f for their filthy
kitchen i'll take it down tomorrow
personally yeah when it's up to the
standard of an a now move your asses the
staff worked through the night
the flight's coming out of this one
cleaning every inch of the restaurant i
certainly was gonna have gordon come
through and say what is the matter here
did you not listen
a thorough cleaning is the first step
that sante la brea has taken in the
right direction
but before gordon can change the menu or
the food he needs to change its owner
good morning
good morning sir how you feeling
very good thank you so much i'm talking
yesterday yes it was very tough really
tough but tougher than i expected what
worries me is that the burden is on
these
you're not letting go you're not
releasing any that pressure
it must be so frustrating inside
because nobody's listening dean that's
the problem the chef's not even
listening you employ them they don't
employ you
you have to know
how to talk to these staff
you're correct yeah
we're now standing on the top of the
canyon
nobody yeah can hear us
so what i want you to do
is
let it out
let's start off with mark first yeah
what have you got to say to him
get the [ __ ] out of my life i don't want
you around yeah
that's it
that's how you tell staff
pathetic
here we go
mark understand that you're here to run
the restaurant yeah not to run crap up
my walls start listening to me now chef
aurelio if you
ever leave my kitchen that state again
look for a new job yeah little [ __ ]
aurelio
why what what's going on with you didn't
i tell you to go ahead and clean the
goddamn refrigerator
[ __ ]
it's not difficult it's business you
have to get a grip
before it's too late
i want to know from you
face to face that you are going to
accept responsibility and more
importantly take control i've got to
hear you it is hard for me to let go but
you know i have to take chef ramsay's
advice mark that's better good
listen no more [ __ ] no more [ __ ]
[ __ ] around no more whatever it is
that you bring no more punctuate [ __ ]
and don't put the mirror here them okay
i want to put that there just do it for
me this time please this just just this
time what the hell no more okay no more
excellent i really give it to him your
limp dick i really what the [ __ ] i know
you for so long and i know your family i
was stupid enough one one time three
times four times six times ten times i
took you back man who the [ __ ] is in
charge in this [ __ ] kitchen
good well done now that
sounds like a boss it feels great to
just scream out and say those things i'm
not used to doing that
wake up
idiots
last one
here we go
you [ __ ] idiots
excellent
good
hey
gordon right now kind of gave me a
little bit more confidence i'm ready now
to go ahead and do my job a lot better
how'd you feel
great having completed the exercise dean
returns to sante and puts gordon's
lesson into action unfortunately it's
with his son what the hell happened to
all my apples here oh please man i took
this [ __ ] out
i don't want to see the end of the
bottles here i took them out i'm not
putting them back don't talk to me like
this
okay don't [ __ ] even if i'm [ __ ]
wrong
do it
my dad exploded it was a kodak [ __ ]
moment man there is a [ __ ] boss here
so don't argue about everything
just do it it's my [ __ ] i'm
responsible
[ __ ] he laid it out that like little
bellow the [ __ ] flaming [ __ ] came out
it was awesome it was great at the end
of your sentences say but i'll do
whatever you want sir okay
am i the boss here or not you are then
listen listen to me that's it
after dean released his frustration
everything settled down just in time for
gordon to inspect the kitchen good
peppers
fresh yes
good gordon came in and he kind of
checked everything out and yeah
everything was good it was clean
top-notch welcome back yes yeah
yeah keep it there yes yes
thank god the f did not stay more than
you know 10 hours
overnight
with the kitchen now in proper working
condition gordon turns his attention to
the food two specials on the menu sniper
yes first dish is a halibut we're gonna
cook it in the marinade second dish
salad or shrimp local shrimp it's really
nice to see chef ramsay be able to take
his genus aqua and bring it down to our
level like we're doing ghetto gordon
shrimp dotted around it's a celebration
of california and now on halibut
two vibrant straightforward dishes it's
30 minutes before dinner service and
although everything appears to be moving
in the right direction gordon gathers
the group for an important meeting now
the
yesterday
there were some serious infractions in
this restaurant yes spoiled food
yeah problems
throughout yes
serious do what you have to do
sir put your hands in front of you
[Music]
do what you have to do
sir put your hands in front of you homes
together
i had whoa like what
[Music]
what the heck is that what did i do i
said where did i break the law
it was a scary moment
i am fed up
up to here with you walking around
picking up after your chef running
around after your sons
after mark
tonight you're not doing that
you're not touching anything tonight
you're going to tell them exactly what
yours do
run your business vocally
you're not getting arrested you silly
billy hey relax look at him he's about
to cry jesus i see what you mean yes
that's right my dad's supposed to be a
manager he's supposed to be verbally
conducting the situation as opposed to
like physically cleaning him back to
people
thank you bob
okay first table just about to arrive
let's go good luck by the way thank you
try not to show the handcuffs keep them
tucked in there yes let's go
okay guys
i'm supposed to be the boss so i can't
help you okay just do it but you can i'm
very very excited about tonight and i'm
looking forward to see this place
swamped now i'm gonna try not to let
things go out of hand good evening nice
to see you come through please sorry
you're waiting this is mark uh hostess
for the evening
can i get you guys some beer and wine
tonight push the specials yes yes
now i'm going to explain the specials
real briefly there we have a spice
halibut which is marinated in fresh
yogurt and then we also have a shrimp
salad the specials are really good
um and they'll be gone quickly
okay this is for table two two halves
special show time i can't i can't clap
but
did you want something to drink
i'll get my ready aunt
you ready
mom he was tricking again oh no he's a
napkin
it was a warm night here in l.a i
thought oh i'll be smart i'll wear a
light shirt hi ladies how are you good
you guys have a reservation please touch
them with these sweaty palms
don't touch the customers
i wasn't sweating that much but the
shirt was catching all of my sweat
oh
i don't like wearing deodorant what can
i tell you stamp it down or dry or
absorb i don't know it's all leaking
over oh my god
[Music]
don't touch anything
i can't help it i was torturing to have
to be in handcuffs and just trying to
work normal way what is this doing here
can you take it to the front please
right now hurry hurry hurry up like run
run run run come on i'm always trying to
lose hands for everyone
now i cannot okay all of it now okay one
halibut for this order this is one of
them for table two
get the halibut ready this is ready
stick take that take that
ladies
enjoy oh it's really good
the specials are nearly sold out which
is great news now mark well he's just
sweating like a pig running around like
headless chicken and sweating all over
the place as for dean i don't think this
guy's finding it easy he's struggling
not to run around after his own style
crazy
this one is this one you sure it's able
to yes yes just go it's fine it's able
to
that's the last halibuts right
dude um you want any of the specials
because i could maybe hold one so i
think they're going to be gone yes
okay i'm going to tell them to hold
those three halibuts okay until they get
your order all right
aurelio aurelio will you hold three uh
the specials on table four give me a
ticket please okay let me take it all
right the halibut
i'm out of right now i'm so sorry
you said you still have one halibut left
what is this gonna do with this one
mark
can you come here for a second
first of all you took an order
mark should be taking order he doesn't
know how to take an order he's he's
always making mistakes and i let it out
listen to me i understand i'm
i understand it's crystal clear it's
crystal clear d crystal i made a poor
choice at that moment it's not like i
spit in someone's suit you guys said a
pauser
thank you so much
thank you thanks for coming in you've
got menus tucked under your sweaty arms
oh
you can't tuck menus under your sweaty
armpits and then hand them out yeah
please
what is he doing now
menu is tucked under his armpit gordon
please send him home since i don't need
him it's your [ __ ] memory stopped the
[ __ ] has to leave
my house was very very bad sweaty
armpits and he put the menu under his
arm
you have to take care of that it was
ugly
go home and change that shirt god damn
it please please just run back okay run
back you got it you guys do something
[Music]
as mark heads home to get a new shirt
back at the restaurant customers are
lining up and gordon is on a mission of
his own hello sir
i've got a friend that sweats a lot i'm
looking for a really strong
antiperspirant but really strong thank
you
and i'll take both of these thank you
boss
thank you
it's a different shirt
it's heavier i'll probably swipe more
but at least people won't see it because
the dark shirt hopefully if this one
takes the sweat gordon if i kick my
[ __ ] ass
sorry yeah
okay
okay
thank you sir okay hey
quick
jesus christ
secret made for a lady strong enough for
a man
he's a [ __ ] funny little army bastard
all right come here let's go
i would like to think
you've learned your lesson look at me
if eon does these yes yes i want i
guarantee they're gonna run your
business yes and not pick up things yes
bob do the honours please thank you i'm
positive yeah don't fall back to your
old ways
[Music]
thank you obviously
let's go dino move huh yes yes yes yes
come on
[Music]
no no no aorita when you're ready i can
take another order let me know
once dean's cuffs are released his
managerial skills are put to the test
there's a hair in our face no way and
then her posture was cold
oh my
[Music]
make another order of penny it's gonna
take long i don't know if they went away
do it now i'm waiting to boil this [ __ ]
man just take the hot water from here
i don't want to take it easy
relaxing
i just want a really to understand
what's really going on i needed to be
the boss i needed to actually do my job
you wanna cook
i don't wanna cook i want you to go just
listen to me go to the back don't stay
here i wanna stay here and you're gonna
do what i'm asking just do it
really stupid
[ __ ] what a [ __ ] attitude
after another disappointing dinner
service comes to an end thank you thank
you thank you gordon tries to make sense
of one of the most bizarre evenings he's
ever witnessed the good news first
within 15 minutes of announcing the
specials the halibut sold out
dean tonight showed
significant signs
of becoming a better manager
unfortunately i had to handcuff you in
order to get that out of you
[Music]
the biggest problem still in this
restaurant is the food
the feedback is the food is bland boring
and barely mediocre tomorrow
we are going to relaunch this restaurant
i want
people to say la sante
yes
is
the healthy restaurant where the food
tastes great if there were ever a
restaurant that needed a makeover it was
sante la brea and gordon's crew worked
through the night to pull it off excited
big big big day today take off your
blindfolds
then you
spontaneous
clean fresh
and green this is beautiful
we decluttered the canopy inviting fresh
here we go outside patio
no
dirty white curtain fresh shades
hand-painted blinds new benches oh this
is [ __ ] comfortable man look at the
color of it nice new vibrant
it's almost like they dream materialized
everything i was dreaming about just
came in flashing in my face what a
change what a vibrant
sexy healthy change awesome i moved to
tears so much because he's a brilliant
man so cool
ready to go inside
yes
look at this
oh my god oh my god oh my god we painted
the entire restaurant we added a
beautiful mural on the wall it was
floored i mean if my mouth could like
unhook it would have done that no more
tacky plastic tablecloths a proper
healthy vibrant fresh restaurant no
clutter you too just don't clutter the
place up again
this is what la wants this makes an
incredible statement they took what we
had and they made it better and smarter
and beautiful
now this oh my god the menu
absolutely absolutely crucial when you
come into something
healthy
and vibrant
oh jesus oh why is the wife dad got
really emotional when he saw the new
menu i'm so happy to see my dad happy
we're not looking through 150 bits of
crap it's fresh and if it's not fresh
it's not on there i'm happy for you you
deserve it and your sons deserve it
thank you man no question this is a good
beginning i would never ever be able to
do it without chef hands okay absorb
have some fun i'll see you in 5-10
minutes yes well done
[Music]
in preparation for the big re-launch
gordon introduces the staff to the new
dishes
gone is the bland mogodufu and dried-out
fish in their place
wonderful chill tomato soup egg white
frittata the eggplant sea bass castle
the lentils the salads and your favorite
the tofu yeah it's been grilled it's the
most important night so far of santa
deliver mark you're hosting tonight
greet sit them down don't take any
orders you got it no worries well don't
just stand there staring at the food get
some knife and fall to taste it
it was an amazing day today brand new
restaurant brand new menu brand new
feeling brand new man
it's relaunch night and time for the
world premiere of the new sante la brea
hi how are you guys tonight
what are we doing we're okay i don't
want to see claudia here all right i
want everything to be clean at all times
okay halibut wonderful wonderful you
just see that
you like the cheese appetizer sure this
mushroom with the cheese first and then
the tuna the beet salad thank you man do
you decide if you'd like any wine
santa barbara santa barbara you got it
thank you thank you
what are you doing can i you don't want
me to bring one i thought he wants me to
sell wine so i'm trying to do you want
me to just tell them then okay mark once
again he didn't listen to my instruction
and he was taking an order and uh i
wanted to take control of that
i already told you once who the [ __ ] is
it john don't take an order i won't i
won't okay relax i won't tell you once
i'm telling you
dean is the boss dean is the owner
dean's word is gold
dean's feeling the pressure as more and
more customers arrive at sante to put
things in in its own place and don't eat
don't drink don't do anything here this
is not good okay whenever i see that i'm
gonna be best
and his kitchen staff is starting to
feel it too just hurry up a little you
gotta run a little bit
hurry up a little bit i need the food
out i can do those two things at the
same time just listen to what i'm saying
do it fast
look keep in mind what i say okay what
what i'm keeping in mind what i say god
damn it stop it goodbye
[ __ ] out of my life i'll do it next
let's go
be right with you in a second you want
to treat me like he's
ugly obvious employee that's a [ __ ]
i'm not like the other guys
where is our grilled cheese in our
hummus dang what come
here what's going on what the [ __ ] is
going on
what's the matter
i'm here
get out i'm tired of the [ __ ]
i really are
[ __ ] relaunch night come on
what's going on what the [ __ ] is going
on
what's the matter
all
right
i don't know
been up with dean's new management style
chef aurelio takes off during the
restaurant's most important dinner
service i really are [ __ ] renault
tonight come on
[ __ ]
what happened he's going like this you
know going slowly i can't [ __ ] wait
for it i said hurry up and listen to me
you don't listen so god damn it i don't
care enough already it's the end of the
line i'm not gonna take it anymore
this is unbelievable the [ __ ] chefs
run dean's going [ __ ] crazy what were
created a monster said run your business
but don't start really slamming into
everybody the restaurant's filling up
this guy's [ __ ] mad i just wanna i
wanna say i'm sorry to the champ branson
i wanna tell him who is dean you know
like he's not a good man come here i
just wanna say i'm okay no no but listen
listen come here this is important this
is launch night i can't beg the [ __ ]
you do care don't you yeah i bet you're
on my mind i listen
to me at least pay me the rest of the
money yo that's all you [ __ ] care
about i'm not going to beat you i
and i want to war without faith okay how
much money you're owed you owe me 14.
okay here
no no no no no come here there's 100.
okay the register comes after service
please
i am going to do this tonight because of
him okay thank you
thank you
come here calm down
big deep breath yeah pretend you're in a
yoga class just
cool now discipline yeah but don't screw
it okay big deep breath
it's an hour into dinner service right
thank you yes and aurelio's absence has
caused a backup in the kitchen grill
full portion so he's staying front yeah
yeah
[Music]
out in the dining room customers are
left waiting for their food we've been
sitting here for like 15 minutes 15
minutes only i have some people waiting
here for longer than that sorry about
that
this is brand new
i was watching everything fall apart no
food coming out our customers were like
waiting hungry waiting hungry waiting
hungry with a dining room full of hungry
customers gordon tries to salvage the
evening we started off
badly
yes really badly can we at least finish
strong you have to look at me motivate
the team as well yes get a grip yes
let's go yes
breathe deep
don't worry about me don't worry about
anything just do the best you can see
bands for table one right you want go
okay one more chicken this restaurant
belongs to all of us eggplants
we all have a lot of passion for it
now it seems like we're closer together
look at it it's beautiful
i learned a lot from this experience
about myself what i'm capable of what i
can do learn how to manage this place
after a less than spectacular start the
staff at sante la brea rallies and pulls
off a successful relaunch thank you
thank you very much thank you
we've come a long way since the
beginning of the week trust me this
place definitely felt like a completely
different restaurant from the one i
entered when i first arrived here hey
each and every one of you cared full of
passion
energetic and more importantly we didn't
give up
work together as a team yes you guys
are a family okay
good night good to see you thank you so
much line wise good to see you too put a
smile on that
good
face
good night yeah
i need two minutes with you guys give me
two minutes please yes all right take a
seat
okay
you have everything you need yes to make
this place successful
i honestly truly believe in it
so manage it and don't be scared that's
right i seriously want this to work i'm
rooting for your success thank you so
much
genius thank you again thank you thank
you sir
make it work you got two great boys
there huh
take care
thank you so much
[Music]
you